[Música]
el litio ha adquirido gran importancia
en las últimas décadas debido a su papel
clave en la fabricación de baterías para
dispositivos electrónicos entre otros
temas En consecuencia su demanda ha
aumentado al tiempo que muchos países
productores de este elemento se mueven
hacia nacionalizar la industria que lo
regula En beneficio de su economía
Mientras tanto otros buscan
desesperadamente Entrar en este mercado
estamos hablando del nuevo oro para el
análisis de esta pregunta y de otras más
vamos a dar el saludo a Marcela Vélez
pickert quien es periodista
especializada en finanzas y economía
internacional en fintech y en desarrollo
de mercados emergentes también está en
la mesa de directo América Juan Pablo
lucumí nuestro periodista económico Juan
Pablo saludo para usted en esta mañana
Buenos días un placer estar acá y saludo
para nuestra invitada Marcela Marcela
cómo está
Buenos días Muchas gracias Pues bien los
dos citados para conversar sobre este
tema que es emergente cuál es la
importancia Marcela del litio Y a qué se
debe este creciente interés por su
explotación
como bien lo mencionaste al al en la
introducción el litio es un material
clave para la transición energética
especialmente por su rol en las baterías
para los vehículos eléctricos el
transporte es la segunda fuente de
dióxido de carbono de emisiones
contaminantes después de la electricidad
y la calefacción entonces para lograr
esos objetivos de reducir las emisiones
Ojalá acero para cumplir el acuerdo
climático de París es necesario
transformar todo el parque automotor que
hoy se mueve a bencina gasolina como le
digan o diesel pasarlo a puentes más
sustentables que no emitan como en este
caso los vehículos eléctricos y ahí el
litio para las baterías es fundamental
podríamos entonces hablar por favor ya
que empezamos hablando del tema
climático acerca de bueno por ejemplo a
Gabriel Boris se le critica mucho de que
impulsó esta nacionalización de las
Industrias del litio pero usted está
hablando como nos lo explica acerca de
que es beneficioso para el medio
ambiente hay personas que lo critican
porque él desde su campaña decía bueno
no vamos a explotar minerales y demás
Pero entonces cuál es el diferencial del
litio en este caso
ahí Juan Pablo ha tocado un punto muy
importante y que creo va a ser clave en
el conflicto del manejo que tengan los
gobiernos a futuro porque está este
conflicto por un lado de reducir
emisiones de luchar contra el cambio
climático y por otro lado no podemos
tener una transición energética sin los
materiales necesarios la agencia
internacional de energía proyecta que se
necesita aumentar en seis veces el
suministro de litio cobre níquel cobalto
vaya varios materiales minerales que se
tienen que extraer de la tierra Cuál es
la defensa que ha hecho el presidente
Gabriel borich para su plan de explotar
el litio Es que la fórmula que está
buscando para explotar este mineral va a
ser más sustentable hay dos formas de
explotar litio uno de roca dura y otro
desde la salmueras de los salares en el
caso de chile tiene las
una de las principales reservas de
salares es la forma en que se extraen
chile desde el Solar de atacama y ahora
lo que se hace Es que se evapore el agua
y se procesan esa esos sedimentos para
extraer el litio y
hay cuestionamientos A qué tan
sustentables son esas fórmulas borich
está apostando por una fórmula que se
llama extracción directa pero que
todavía está en fase de prueba
Marcela Cuáles son los principales
beneficios y riesgos de nacionalizar a
las Industrias alrededor del litio
pasando ya más al tema económico
hay que tener hay que precisar bien no
hay mucha Claridad todavía Cuál es el
alcance de este plan en el caso de chile
entiendo que es diferente al caso de
México que tiene un aspecto mucho más
Estatal Aunque México actualmente no es
un actor principal en la industria de
litio como lo es chile que tiene las
principales reservas uno de los
principales productores en el caso del
plan que ha anunciado el gobierno
chileno lo que se busca es recuperar el
control de los recursos dejar por
escrito que los recursos de ese salar y
otros son propiedad del estado y que las
mineras solo están ahí para explotar
bajo contratos por ejemplo Se confirmó
que se respete el contrato con albemale
que es una de las principales mineras
con yacimientos o operaciones en el
salar de atacama es un contrato que va
hasta dos mil cuarenta y tres la
política que ha anunciado incluye
también la creación una empresa Estatal
Cuáles son las ventajas el argumento del
gobierno es que más recursos de litio o
de su explotación van a quedar para el
país Cuáles son las desventajas El
problema es que puede crear mucha
incertidumbre o desincentivos para que
llegue la inversión extranjera la
minería es una actividad que requiere de
mucho capital y uno de los problemas que
tenemos en Latinoamérica es la
dependencia del capital extranjero para
toda ese tipo de actividades entonces
cualquier política cualquier
incertidumbre Respecto a los derechos de
explotación o al rol que va a tener el
estado en esa actividad puede generar
desincentivos para que lleguen esos
capitales sin necesarios precisamente
una de las preguntas es mirar el
panorama mundial porque pues chile ocupa
el segundo lugar después de Australia y
debajo de él está la segunda economía
más grande del mundo está China luego
está Argentina o sea es un panorama muy
importante pero entonces cómo podría
seguir aprovechándolo pues teniendo en
cuenta que también en el Triángulo del
litio junto con Bolivia y Argentina está
al 60% de la producción mundial Entonces
como chile podría aprovechar esta
carrera diciendo también que quiere
llegar superar incluso a Australia
hay dos dos ejes A mi parecer uno es
dando las condiciones necesarias creando
un marco atractivo para atraer la
inversión y ahí no se trata solamente de
si hay una empresa nacional que también
explota litio o no sino de
respetar los contratos de crear
seguridad jurídica pero también ofrecer
otras ventajas Como por ejemplo una
cadena de suministros por ejemplo de
capital humano de tecnología el plan que
ha dicho chile es querer superar
Australia y una de las grandes ventajas
que tiene Australia es que a partir de
su otra actividad minera de cobre y
otros minerales ha desarrollado toda una
industria más avanzada Lamentablemente
en Latinoamérica nos quedamos todavía en
exportadores de materias primas y no
sabemos aprovechar eso para
transformarnos en en Industrias más
sofisticadas que generen empleos de
mejor paga ahí está la clave y como bien
ha señalado Juan Pablo el Triángulo de
litio Argentina Bolivia chile tiene las
reservas tenemos como lo mencionamos al
inicio el oro de la Nueva Era y la
pregunta es si estamos listos para hacer
las reformas necesarias para
aprovecharlas pues es Marcela Vélez
speaker periodista especializado en
finanzas y en economía internacional
Gracias a ustedes por estar con nosotros
en directo América gracias por la
invitación También usted Gracias Juan
Pablo y más tarde nos vemos para hablar
de más noticias de economía Así es vamos
a hacer una pequeña pausa ya regresamos
con más quédese con nosotros
[Música]